some more daily gaming news for you
Capcom has just announced that Resident
Evil 4 has sold over 3 million units in
its first two days after release which
is Bonkers especially considering so
many different facets of the games
industry have long held the belief that
horror games don't sell the story from
capcom's website says Resident Evil 4 is
a remake of the original 2005 title in
addition to reworking the story and
modernizing the game feel the 2023
release will provide both fans of the
series and newcomers alike with a fresh
gameplay experience featuring highly
immersive visuals powered by The Cutting
Edge Graphics technology of capcom's
proprietary re engine along with
securing high scores on online review
sites the title gone and praise and
attention following the release of the
Chainsaw demo in which players could
enjoy the opening of the game resulting
in worldwide sales of the title
surpassing 3 million units in the first
two days after the game's release they
also noted that cumulative shipments of
the game in the series now exceed 135
million units since it first debuted in
1996.